molto più a sud dietro questa roccia c'è
un'isola solitaria terra di menestrelli
ed isolane sono di frutta gustosa e di
piante pericolose
gli abitanti gentili ho detto gentili
bene sono john hammond e questo e
filicudi
[Musica]
ahrarara venite con me signori signore
quest'oggi la missione e acqua abbiamo
bisogno dei nostri migliori agenti
cascata rossa ma certo la squadra in
forma come sempre bene cannuccia sicura
abbiamo la gente rodriguez libellula
sorridente tettona qui il frangente il
cupo di mare fu poi basta la gente moda
zio ben gen
abbiamo tutti i convocati la busta
rutelli si schiera la gente rodriguez la
partenza sarà immediato vogliamo
risposte oggi
adesso cercate di essere più in
incognito possibile cercate di non dare
nell'occhio
[Musica]
questa la consegna a punto da star
allora ragazzi siamo pronti un pop
secret trovate john hammond non era
morto nell'avventura giurassico scusi
stiamo cercando benvenuti cosa vi porta
island stiamo cercando giovani ma mai
sentito nominare a buttarla qualcosa
cioè alla ricerca di un nostro amico
dovrà prendere un caffè
innanzitutto poi per john hammond
avrebbe voglia di un caffè volevamo
volevamo offrirle un caffè usate mi
presento mi parlavi di voi come l'estero
sono le curiosità e leggenda è stata
rossa la missione sul tamigi a tutti ciò
che zio ben cosciente la sua missione su
al volo li accompagni sempre che
qualcosa vada bene nostri ospiti
gli agenti sono stanchi hanno fatto un
lungo viaggio
buonasera
no no no non avete molto altro secolo
che servizio impeccabile da dei signori
agenti grazie
eviterei di utilizzare questo servizio
così pregiato per evitare che friedrich
e chi per lui lo lati qua ce ne sono
tanti e si muovono in banchi
no tutto gli attesi nella meravigliosa
verifica si sopra il vino architettura
eccolo qua a proposito di quantità
ciechi disegni rosa rita non mi sembra
una persona molto socievole e mi qui in
quantità dove questo giardino curato
tutto da me
comprerei mai possiamo cercarli me ne
servirebbero a guardare non tocca
assolutamente non toccheremo 3 noi siam
su di noi deve riposare e figure al qui
a sinistra
eccolo è la fede ricche scontroso e
troppo nervoso il frigorifero ore dalla
medicina subito ott perdonate friedrich
non è una persona molto affabile che vi
consiglierei
150 scatti vedo come la tiene lontana
[Musica]
io mi accetti di l'acqua no no no signor
mauti sarà un piacere per me conoscerla
e avere l'onore di partecipare
attivamente alla prosperità e uno
sviluppo della vostra meravigliosa isola
ps che è un ottimo analizzatore
grafologo magari davanti un buon
bicchiere riempiamo qualche offre
qualcosa ma io ce l'ho oggi lo scotch
personalissimo prof
ma ve lo fate tratta fi pubblici dallo
scotch indigeno uno scotch e delizioso e
liam indigeno cresce un po di razza
indice nostri
guarda che hai passato grazie a cui
venne qui era molto molto molto molto
molto molto molto molto attivo
riguardante la prosperità dell'isola lo
aiutai a combinare degli affari a
rimuovere un po di ascensori sì tutto
qui scusate ma potevo andare
mancava il biglietto
vediamo questa sinistra blue eyes 28
sotto la lampada guarda sotto
eccolo eccolo qua il tubo e il tuo
giardino non quello degli altri
youtube erano nate mozza rita è un
ottimo giardinieri ma in conto
affabilità lascia molto a desiderare ma
è pieno di dubbi ragazzo ritrovato a
bagnetto settimo a destra cosa che c'è
tema dove ti ho scritto y uguali xa al
quadrato
non ci credo ma valigia vuota di sergio
era una delle nostre milan agente moda a
controllarmi nella verità moda questa è
decisamente la validità della gente nola
siamo estranei nella sua stanza
certamente non si può entrare dice volta
carotone
non ho più tempo mi sono addosso fatico
a dormire la notte
temo che presto mi verranno a prendere o
dio la porta eccoli john john hall non
filippo che fai tu di dove pernottava
purtroppo con un nono posto
fredrik sopra sicuramente non so
mandiamo di farsi signore le posso dire
una cosa perfavore
proprio adesso che siamo adesso ad una
roma che mi chiama e ha bisogno di no
[Musica]
ma non è questo la camera padronale di
dio e quella ok
oddio ma erano bellissimi abbiamo
bisogno di prove allora le immagini che
sto per fare di vedremo davvero
stracciati il cuore allora viva tutto
guardate lui chimere e scrivono filippo
mi controllano continuamente ormai sono
diventato il massimo nelle normali e
fortunatamente sono riuscito a
nascondere la sacra school you essenza
stessa dell'isola non la troveranno mai
gli isolani isolato la custodisce hanno
preso filippo chi l'ha preso
loro chi i cattivi ma molto simile a
friedrich
la foto che avete fatto insieme due era
dove eravate
l'isola regionali che monselice
religione un isolato dietro vero dove
l'avete fatta quella foto mi sono
isolato
stiamo cercando lo scoop bisogna vedere
se siete degni
possedere e cosa dobbiamo fare
il sacro scoppio prima di parlare con me
ovviamente li nell'ordine di 5 buio
dovrete superare l'ultimo in do min
qual è un tipo molto comunale al più
persone e custodiscono e meno sono al
sicuro
un segreto cosa è un segreto
sì sì certo risposta esatta del in grado
di custodire il cuore o alle brutte
lodiamo intenta al giardiniere vediamo
lo scudieri nostra abbiamo trovato avete
trovato abbiamo trovato il giovane
isolato isolato avete recuperato lo
scoop casco kg se abbiamo uno scooter
finora ragazzi temi lo studio ha un po
di mare o di marco di mare no ragazzi ma
poi rimane era povera paolo lo sapevo
c'era un agente in fretta
questi sono io e filippo è così rosea i
cattivi non sono mai riusciti a
impossessarsi rischio è infiltrato da di
voi il cattivo e anche filippo ora lo
uccideranno e porteranno via schio per
sempre grato ci credo un po di mare già
tradito ragazzi bisogna farlo il caso
tmg guida vi sono pure cambiato la
camicia
veloci per favore ragazzi
[Musica]
uccidetelo cosa fanno girando
vero traditore è chi ha potere delitto
insomma
[Musica]
questo perde lo scudo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
niente
capelli
quindi con